hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be a breakdown of Marvel's
daredevil Netflix TV series they've been
making a whole bunch of Netflix
announcements like they just cast Mike
Colter as Luke Cage so I'll talk about
that stuff too
so in order of premiere dates here's
what's going on in the Marvel verse
daredevil then Jessica Jones then Luke
Cage then iron fist there's a rumor that
daredevil is going to premiere May 1st
on the same day as Avengers age of
Ultron they might push that around a
little bit but it makes sense that
they're gonna release it somewhere near
age of Ultron just to maximise on
awareness they'll spend no less than a
hundred and fifty million dollars
promoting age of Ultron so they're gonna
capitalize on that as much as possible
so Charlie Cox is playing Matt Murdock
we're gonna watch him become daredevil
in the course of this series it's based
on the Man Without Fear the Frank Miller
miniseries it was only five issues in
the comics the artists on it John Romita
Jr is actually blowing it up with Jeff
John's on Superman right now any time I
see him on a new title I just think kick
ass whatever like kick ass Superman
so think of this as kick-ass daredevil
I'm a really huge fan of his artwork so
be sure whenever the episodes turn
airing that you look in the backgrounds
for Easter eggs for John Romita Jr art
sometimes they have posters hanging in
scenes they'll have the original artwork
from the comic book just to explain the
rest of the main cast for the show
Deborah Ann Woll is gonna be Karen page
if you remember her she was just a can
be on True Blood she's one of my
favorite gingers on TV right now so I'm
looking forward to seeing her in this
superhero universe she does John really
well I was a fan of the Jessica Hamby
character at least for the first couple
of seasons I didn't watch True Blood
after like season 3 or 4 Karen page is
the longest-running love interest for
daredevil in the comics so she'll be
Charlie Cox's love interest in this
story in the context of the daredevil
universe she works at the law firm that
Matt Murdock works at like you'd expect
their relationship usually takes a
downhill turn once he reveals his secret
identity to her but that remains to be
seen whether or not he's gonna do that
during the series but I feel like they
will go there there was a brief period
in the 80s when she became Daredevils
sidekick so he might get to see vampire
Jessica kick some butt strong females
are a really big theme in Netflix shows
right now like orange is the new black
so it stands to reason that they would
cast someone who could do action as well
as do the love interest drama stuff
Vincent D'Onofrio is going to be the big
villain
kingpin of course he will be bald I know
there was some question about that as to
how true to the role he would be Vincent
D'Onofrio is known as being more of a
method actor like he'll go too crazy
links to inhabit new characters I'm not
really into procedural so I don't watch
a lot of law and order but he is a
really good actor so I'm excited to see
him inside the Marvel verse Elden Henson
is gonna be foggy Nelson he's Matt
Murdock's law partner and a good friend
you probably remember him as Pollitz
from hunger games mockingjay rosario
Dawson also great actress is gonna play
Claire temple the really cool thing
about her is that in the comics she's
actually the romantic interest for Luke
Cage since they just cast Mike Colter as
Luke Cage Luke Cage is obviously not
going to appear in the daredevil series
because they finished shooting that a
while ago we might get references to him
but it remains to be seen whether or not
Rosario Dawson's character will have a
relationship with Mike Coulter's
character all the characters are
crossing over and the defenders movie
and some will appear in each other's
series but they haven't really explained
who is gonna be in what I would expect
there to be at least a loose crossover
like in the way the arrow and flash
crossover Scott Glenn is gonna play
stick he's Daredevils sensei who teaches
him how to fight I'm a fan of Scott
Glenn but we'll see how he looks once
he's in character on the page I don't
buy him as this wise martial arts master
but if he can pull it off more power to
him I'll withhold judgment till I
actually see him even though they're
adapting Frank Miller story The Man
Without Fear there will be some minor
changes for TV like there is a hint
arrow character that they created just
for the show so just spoilers for the
comic book I'm just gonna explain what
the broad storyline is it is the origin
story retold again so we'll watch him go
from being a kid to becoming daredevil
it's wiping the slate clean for everyone
that saw the Ben Affleck daredevil and
live to tell the tale I know those were
dark times so in the context of the
story heat grows up the son of a boxer
named battlin Jack Murdock his father
gets tied up with the mob refuses to
take a dive so the mob comes after him
which is Daredevils big call-to-action
he's approached by a stick who is played
by Scott Glenn who teaches him how to
become a warrior in the story it's
actually radioactive chemicals that
blind him I don't know how crazy they'll
get with it normally getting splashed in
the face with radioactive chemicals
would melt your face off the story takes
place in New York in Hell's Kitchen for
those that have ever been there it's
still called Hell's Kitchen but it's not
the hell
kitchen of New York today ever since
mayor Giuliani in real life Disney fied
Times Square things got so much cleaner
like II cleaned up Hell's Kitchen - that
being said in the Netflix series it's
gonna be in modern day but it will be
the Hell's Kitchen of Frank Miller's
story like it'll be dark gritty dirty
dangerous one bigger change from the
comic to the Netflix series is they're
not doing Elektra she's in the comic
book story but they're not gonna do her
in the TV series but they'll probably do
is gives some aspects of her character
like the more butt-kicking aspects to
Karen page she's not gonna be Elektra
like she's not gonna turn into Elektra
she'll just be the one doing some butt
kicking once Matt Murdock becomes
daredevil once he takes on the persona
it becomes a revenge story he's gonna
start out in the black suit but he will
get the red suit by the end of the
series there was some question initially
as to the way they were gonna release
the episodes but now it looks like
they're just gonna dump on traditional
Netflix style all at once a lot of the
comic book series takes place when he's
in college they might montage past a lot
of that because most of the behind the
scenes footage we've seen is of him as a
lawyer in Hell's Kitchen so they might
just blow through the backstory in the
first two episodes with the exception of
flashbacks the series all the Netflix
series are gonna be chronological so
daredevil will come first and then after
the events of that Jessica Jones the
events of that series will pick up and
then so on with Luke Cage and iron fist
and then the defenders I mean each of
the series is gonna tell a bit of an
origin story so there will be a lot of
flashbacks but for the most part think
of them as being chronological the
Marvel films have kind of played around
with how that's gonna happen in Phase
three
honestly when it comes to the daredevil
series I'm really looking forward to it
being super violent they did say because
it's Netflix they can be super violent
unlike the ABC shows like agents of
shield and agent Carter those are
network TV shows so they can't get is
crazy and then there's the absence of
Elektra she's a huge character in Frank
Miller's series so either they're gonna
include her as a surprise or they're not
conclude her at all and I said they were
can include her earlier they just they
haven't listed her on the cast list
she wasn't seen behind the scenes so I'm
assuming that they didn't include her
they just wrote her out over the series
a lot of the comic book takes place in
Boston but they shot the series in
Hell's Kitchen so I think that there's
moving the story it's a Hell's Kitchen -
which is actually where he was born
remember that it's a miniseries so it's
gonna be relatively self-contained but
it
connect with the other Netflix series
they only just now cast a couple of the
Netflix characters Krysten Ritter is
gonna be Jessica Jones my culture
obviously Luke Cage right now my
favorite pick for iron fist is master
key but they haven't cast that character
yet they're still looking Stephen
tonight who's the showrunner our
daredevil announced that they finished
filming just a little bit ago they
announced Krysten Ritter several weeks
ago so it's possible that they did have
a cameo from Jessica Jones at the end of
the daredevil series if they're gonna
have a Luke Cage cameo in Jessica Jones
then presumably they do the same thing
for every series and there'd be at least
one of the other characters in each of
the series before the defenders each of
the four characters will get their own
13 episodes series the defenders
miniseries is only going to be 48
episodes one of the big things they have
confirmed about the series if there's
not gonna be a lot of super powers these
are all street-level heroes that's what
they're billing them as so it's gonna be
very realistic so think arrow season 1
they haven't said whether or not they're
gonna do a season 2 for any of the
series I think it's gonna depend on the
success how happy they are with
everything once it airs but it stands to
reason if it's really successful they'll
keep doing it just taking a look at the
way Marvel is choosing to release new IP
I'm really excited about Netflix as a
platform I think what you'll see is once
they get done with these core
street-level heroes they'll start
looking to other characters too so
whenever they hit season 2 of some of
these shows we might see other
characters Punisher is one that I'm
really hoping to see if he makes it into
a movie it would probably only as a
minor cameo I think it's more realistic
that he would show up in one of the
Netflix shows Jessica Jones is
supposedly going to premiere later this
year but that's not confirmed it could
be pushed to early 2016 depending on
when they shoot the pilot there are
rumors that Paul Rudd's Scott Lang could
have a cameo in Jessica Jones the timing
would definitely work out the same way
that Avengers age of Ultron and
Daredevils release working out that's if
they go with The Fault premiere for
Jessica Jones Scott Lang and Jessica
Jones have some crossover in the comics
so that's just why people are thinking
in that direction it's totally confirmed
it's just a rumor but I think it would
be really awesome to see Paul Rudd to
see like a movie character show up in
the Netflix series so let me know what
are you most excited to see and I like
all these new Marvel Netflix series I
mean do you really enjoy that they're
doing this on Netflix and actually
here's a big question for you guys do
you want to see Punisher get his own
Netflix series already want to see him
in a movie
in related news I'm working on an agent
Carter video it'll start on January 6 it
airs the same time agents of shield airs
so if you watch agents of shield
whichever country you live in it's gonna
be on the same channel during the same
time that normally airs it'll run for 8
episodes and then agents of shield will
come back I will do weekly videos just
like I normally do for agents of shield
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything in addition to the
live-action TV stuff they are working on
a guardians of the galaxy cartoon they
haven't announced when they're gonna
start airing episodes it might be
October 2015 so it might not be till the
fall but I will do a video for that too
real soon in related movie news the only
real big recent development is that
scott derrickson the director of dr.
strange posted this fan art a benedict
cumberbatch with the beard they're
calling it comer beard but because it's
fan art I'm not sure whether or not
he'll actually have a beard in the movie
I don't think that he will because it
seems a little silly they tend to tone
things down a little bit when it comes
to the movie so we'll see
Benedict Cumberbatch is awesome but
comer beard is not right now if you're
actually watching this on your mobile
phone or on your tablet you can click up
here for mobile links it's the same as
the links over here but click here to
catch up on what's going on with the
movies in phase 3 and click here for my
top 10 TV shows this year just shows
that I watched I think people a little
confused by that thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five I'll see
you guys tonight
you